et compris le vert c'est donc la couleur
politique du moment ce n'est pas un
hasard si françois fillon a choisi
aujourd'hui pour sa rentrée les plages
des côtes-d'armor
d'autant que les algues vertes qui les
oreilles sont plus ce ne sont plus
seulement un problème écologique elles
sont aussi officiellement un problème de
santé publique
agnès monteux tristan le brasse alors
vous avez vu le tueur et le voilà alors
ça c'est la zone
cavalier vacances d'écourter pour
françois fillon venu voir cette plage où
un cheval est mort et où son cavalier a
été sauvé in extremis il ya trois
semaines
un incident qui prend de l'ampleur un
rapport vient de confirmer la toxicité
parfois mortelles des émanations de ces
marais de l'état va prendre toutes ses
responsabilités et va prendre à sa
charge le nettoyage des plages qui sont
les plus touchés c'est à dire de celles
sur lesquelles il peut y avoir un risque
de santé publique
le problème ce faux sur les zones
difficiles d'accès où on ne peut pas
ramasser ces algues elles pourrissent
prisonnière sous ses croûtes et des
poches d'un gaz mortel de l'hydrogène
sulfuré se forment des concentrations
très élevées plus de 1000 parties par
million ont parfois été mesurées sur la
plage où le cheval est mort quand la
moitié suffirait à tuer un homme
principaux responsables en plus des
rejets des villes l'agriculture
intensive trop déjections trop d'engrais
qui finissent en nitrates dans la mer ce
qui dope les ags même type qu'il existe
un code de la route il nous faut un code
de l'agriculture qui sont complètement
différents des pratiques qu'on a obtenus
au niveau de l'agriculture d'accord
répondre les agriculteurs qui utilisent
de moins en moins d'engrais et recyclée
de mieux en mieux leurs déjections
pour aller plus loin là par contre il
faudra à l'accompagnement des
agriculteurs des écritures seul n'y
arrivons pas une mission
interministérielle doit se réunir dans
les trois mois pour tenter de définir un
plan d'action contre ces peste verte
malheureusement pour les rives